- I want to talk about Miley.
Amongst other things, she's known for
sticking her tongue out all the time.
- Right.
- Like, all the time.
We're measuring everyone's
tongue on the red carpet here.
- Are you serious?
- To see if they have a
longer tongue than her.
(swishing)
If you had to guess, how big
do you think Miley's tongue is?
- I...it's a pretty good size.
- So, Miley's known for
her long tongue, right?
She always sticks her tongue out
- Yes, that's absolutely
what she's known for.
- So today, we wanted
to acknowledge that by
measuring everyone on
the red carpets tongue.
- Ok.
- So we'd love to measure your tongue.
- Yeah.
- We need to make sure that
yours isn't longer than hers.
- We want to measure from
inside or outside the mouth?
- You choose. I'm going to let you do it.
- Let's put it in your mouth then.
- How deep are you going to go?
- How deep will you let me?
- How deep do you want to go?
- I'd want to go all the way.
- Bad!
- Has this been sterilized?
- Yes.
It's personally, it's
wrapped, so you can unwrap it
if you're actually going to...
- Am I going to get herpes from this?
- No.
- I hope not.
- They're sterile, they're clean.
Let's see how...
- How far does it have to go?
- That's what we're about to find out!
- It's up to you.
- Stick it out for me,
point it out, point it out.
Whoa, whoa.
- Flatten it, and then, no no
- flatten your tongue right there.
- Yeah really...
- Oh damn, bro!
- That's like a two
and a half inch tongue!
- Solid tongue! Solid!
- That looks like a
two-incher right there.
It's a solid tongue.
- That's what it is. I'm so
thankful for a solid tongue.
- Stick it out.
- Out, out. Wow, that's
a three inch tongue.
- That's a solid, meaty
tongue right there.
- Rebecca!
- What can I say, I'm blessed?
- Rebecca! Rebecca!
- That looks like a three and a quarter!
[both] Three and a quarter!
That's a three and a quarter!
- I don't want that number to
represent anything else on me!
- Wow!
- Two and a quarter inches!
- That's good!
- That's the biggest I've ever been, wow.
- It's about one and
three quarters inches.
- Not that long.
- One and three quarters inches,
not the biggest tongue we've seen.
- It'll do.
- Two and a half, two and a half.
- Whooo!
- It might have been
two and three quarters.
- Let's go two and three quarters.
- Yeah, let's go with that.
- Woo hoo! Alright!
- I think that looks
like a two and a half.
- Two and a quarter.
- I say two and a half.
- Thank you, thank you, thank you.
- Maybe it was two and three eighths?
- I don't mean to brag,
but, I've got what it takes.
Wow!
I love it.
- You can go more than that.
- Longer!
- Yeah. Really?
- Okay, that's like a two and a quarter.
- I think you guys have tied tongues.
- What do we have there?
- Oh my god, that's a four inch tongue!
- That's a four! That's a four.
- You're our leader right
now, how do you feel?
(rap music)
- [Voiceover] Are you
guys going to tweet me
and tell me what Miley's is later?
- If you can help us get a hold of her
to measure her tongue, that
would be a dream come true.
- I might hold her down
and measure it later
if you guys don't get her.
- That'll work!
(swishing and creaking)